trois heures d'entretien couronnes 8
années de lutte pour le peuple polonais
lech walesa reçu par le ministre de
l'intérieur rappelle ce soir à la
reprise du travail catastrophe aérienne
en série aujourd'hui alors que 13
personnes ont été tuées à dallas et
autres ont trouvé la mort dans un
atterrissage manqué à hong kong
bonsoir c'était une concession
historique que ce réseau aujourd'hui le
régime de varsovie huit années après la
signature des accords de gdansk
solidarité venait alors de naître le
pouvoir polonais a pour la première fois
cédé se résignant à recevoir les chevals
isr qui en échange d'une négociation
prochaine sur la légalisation du
syndicat dissous appelle à la reprise y
travaillent
jack nannini 12h30
varsovie lech walesa se rend dans une
villa privée où l'attend le général
c'est cela qui chaque ministre
l'intérieur
hilare 200 voitures ces simples mots je
viens ici avec l'espoir de rattraper
sept ans de retard de cette rencontre
aucune image encore mais déjà quelques
informations d'emblée les cheveux les as
a demandé si la reconnaissance de
solidarité serait abordée lors des
négociations le ministre l'intérieur
répondu qu'il n'y aurait pas de question
tabou et un dirigeant de solidarité
actuellement à paris confirme que c'est
un préalable non négociable la wii pour
tous les grévistes de l'exigence de
légaliser celui d'arnage est toujours la
première et la seule condition qui peut
mettre un terme à ce conflit en pologne
est-ce que je nage a osé ce qui peut
reconnaître solidarité et rester au
pouvoir
je pense que si le général josé ce qui
s'entêtait à vouloir interdire
solidarité les perspectives son départ
serait alors quasiment inévitable
en revanche lorsqu'on dit s'il est prête
à reconnaître notre syndicat et gagnera
une certaine autorité et bénéficiera de
meilleures conditions
pour gouverner aussitôt après ces
entretiens qui ont duré près de trois
heures les chevaliers zahar pris la
route de dax qu'il doit rendre compte au
comité de grève de ses premiers
entretiens et c'est le comité de grève
qui prendra ou non la décision de
suspendre le mouvement de protestation
en tout état de cause la crise évolue
donc vers son dénouement il semble bien
que ce spectaculaire revirement du
pouvoir qui hier encore jouer à la
répression s'explique par des raisons
économiques la pologne à bout de souffle
absolument besoin d'une aide financière
internationale et celle ci ne peut venir
que si le pays retrouve son calme
accidents au décollage aujourd'hui à
dallas d'un boeing 727 de la déroute à
delta airlines qui transportait 104
passagers selon un bilan qui reste
provisoire ce soir treize personnes ont
été tuées et une quarantaine d'autres
blessées
alors que l'on ignore encore les causes
précises de l'accident selon les experts
pourrait avoir été provoqué par une
avarie de moteur
frédéric est où une carlingue disloqué
et calcinée c'est tout ce qui reste une
bruine 727 dépelteau airlines l'appareil
venait de jackson mississippi et
repartez pour salt lake city dans l'utah
quand il s'est brutalement écrasé au sol
juste après le décollage avant
d'exploser et de prendre feu
rapidement les secours s'organisent
après les pompiers hélicoptère et
ambulances se relaient pour venir en
aide ou 97 passagers aux sept membres
d'équipage l'aéroport de dallas est
fermée au trafic
des débris du tri-réacteur les op teurs
dégage les corps d'au moins 13 morts
dont un enfant et dirige une trentaine
de blessés vers les hôpitaux de la ville
selon la direction de delta airlines
plusieurs enfants en bas âge se
trouvaient à bord sans avoir été
enregistrés ce qui explique la
difficulté d'établir rapidement un bilan
définitif des victimes
en tout une soixantaine de personnes
sont sorties indemnes de cet accident et
ont pu poursuivre leur voyage
une avarie de moteur pourrait être à
l'origine du crash du boeing 727
un témoin affirme avoir vu des flammes
s'échapper de l'un de ses réacteurs
avant le décollage
ensuite l'appareil aurait manqué de
puissance c'est la troisième fois en
deux ans qu'un accident concerne un
avion de delta airlines
le premier c'était d'ailleurs déroulée
sur le même aéroport de dallas en août
1985 autre accident plus spectaculaire
mais moins meurtrier à l'aéroport de
hong kong un appareil de la caq la
compagnie chinoise a manqué son
atterrissage s'abîmant dans les eaux du
port six passagers ont trouvé la mort
les 83 autres ont pu être sauvés le
mauvais temps serait à l'origine de
l'accident patrice pollet l'aéroport de
hong kong et l'un des plus dangereux du
monde et le vol du trident de la
compagnie chinoise partie de canton
s'est terminée dans la mer
la visibilité était pratiquement nulle a
raconté un rescapé l'avion a heurté
l'entrée de la piste les roues ont été
arrachés et ensuite nous avons continué
sur le vent
l'aéroport international de keita qui ne
dispose que d'une seule piste de 3300
mètres construite sur des terrains
gagnés sur la mer située au fond de la
baie de hong kong
l'aéroport est bordé comme on le voit
ici au fond par des centaines de tours
et d'immeubles où vivent des milliers de
personnes tous les pilotes redoublent de
prudence lorsqu'ils se pose à hong kong
et la proche de la piste très difficile
ne pardonne aucune erreur d'approché
délicate
d'autre part les rependre aux comptes à
une piste d'une largeur normal mais qui
n'a pas beaucoup de gardes sur le côté
donc il est assez facile de sortir de la
piste freinage a certainement une grosse
responsabilité s'il y avait beaucoup
d'eau et que toutes les roues patinent
et il est probable que pilote a eu
dimanche à freiner et dans ce cas en
fonction du freinage plus ou moins bien
répartie droite ou gauche il a pu sortir
de la piste d'un côté 83 personnes sont
parvenues à sortir de l'appareil et
après un bain forcé ont regagné indemme
le rivage mais six autres sont mortes
dont plusieurs membres de l'équipage
colère et déception sans surprise pour
le peuple chilien la nuit dernière la
junte a désigné le général pinochet
comme son candidat au plébiscite
destinée à le maintenir la tête du pays
jusqu'en 1997
la réponse est venue de la rue sans
tarder santiago et d'autres grandes
villes ont été agités par de violentes
manifestations
deux personnes ont été tuées on estime à
700 le nombre des arrestations
bernard benyamin 19h hier à santiago
l'événement tant attendu espéré ou
redouté selon le cas trouve sa
confirmation au balcon du palais de la
moneda le général pinochet vient d'être
désigné candidat des forces armées pour
le référendum du 5 octobre prochain
environ dix mille personnes sont là pour
l'acclamer elles savent que si le oui
l'emporté lors de cette consultation le
général restera au pouvoir jusqu'en 1997
ce qui porterait à 25 ans la durée de
son exercice du pouvoir
au même moment un peu partout dans la
capitale chilienne
un énorme concert de casseroles commence
pour protester contre cette candidature
dans la rue les manifestations s'étaient
formées dès le début de l'après midi
elles sont dispersés en quelques minutes
par les carabiniers un spectacle
désormais classique à santiago
bilan de cette protesta annoncé une
centaine d'arrestations une vingtaine de
blessés mais surtout à mort un jeune
homme de 19 ans tué de deux balles dans
la poitrine pour eux pour tous et
chiliens de l'opposition que le problème
est de savoir si le nom a des chances de
l'emporter
et dans ce cas ci les militaires
tiendront parole en organisant des
élections présidentielles en 1989
de la réponse à ces deux questions
dépend le futur immédiat du chili
d'autant que certains craignent une
généralisation de la violence
d'ici au 5 octobre prochain
la riposte de londres la campagne
terroriste et de républicains irlandais
trois membres présumés de l'ira ont été
abattus par des soldats britanniques qui
hier au centre de l'ulster là même où il
ya dix jours huit militaires anglais
avaient trouvé la mort dans un attentat
de l'armée républicaine irlandaise
philippe harrouard ce sont bien trois
membres de l'ira qui ont été abattus
hier soir par les forces de sécurité sur
une petite route d'irlande du nord
la d3 était un chef de l'organisation
terroriste a révélé la police irlandaise
apparemment l'opération était menée par
le sas
le service spécial de l'armée des
témoins ont vu quatre hommes en civil
monter dans un hélicoptère tout de suite
après la fusillade
ce prêtre appelés sur les lieux affirme
que les trois victimes étaient criblés
de balles
les trois hommes étaient armés ils
avaient tiré sur un camion en
stationnement avant d'être mitraillé par
les forces de sécurité qui visiblement
les surveiller de près côté protestant
on se félicite hautement de l'initiative
des forces de l'ordre et l'on y voit le
premier résultat concret des nouvelles
mesures prises par le gouvernement
britannique pour juguler la vague de
violence en ulster
son de cloche différent chez les
catholiques modérés et les nationalistes
où l'on s'inquiète de ce qui apparaît
comme une exécution pure et simple
ne pouvait-on pas à arrêter les
terroristes des explications sont
réclamées aux autorités à qui il est
demandé de lutter contre le terrorisme
sans sortir de la légalité est
aujourd'hui encore en irlande dans le
secteur catholique de londonderry deux
personnes ont été tuées et une troisième
blessée dans l'explosion d'une bombe
qu'il manipulait la réponse de françois
mitterrand à l'opposition divisée
troublée sur l'opportunité du référendum
sur la nouvelle calédonie en conseil des
ministres le chef de l'état a tenu à
mettre en garde contre les réticences
qui pourrait encore s'exprimer
affirmant que renoncer référendum
saurait renoncer à l'accord lui même les
propos de françois mitterrand rapportés
par claude evin le porte parole du
gouvernement
président de la république a tenu à
insister je le fait que le référendum
est
justement un des éléments du contrat la
france at il dit est obligée non
seulement d'apporter des garanties
juridiques mais elle doit s'engager par
tous ses citoyens
les calédoniens ont été à la merci de
changement de gouvernement
cela n'est plus aujourd'hui acceptable
renoncer au référendum a poursuivi le
président de la république ce serait
renoncer à l'accord même ceux qui s'en
prennent à la forme en fait s'en
prennent au fond elle avait dès sa
rentrée politique raymond barre apporte
son appui à l'action de françois
mitterrand dans une interview à paris
match l'ancien premier ministre affirme
ainsi que les grandes orientations
fixées par le chef de l'état
correspondent à ce qui est nécessaire à
la france
peut-être une aide supplémentaire venu
de l'état pour les syndicats pierre
bérégovoy le ministre de l'économie
envisage la déduction d'une partie des
cotisations syndicales du revenu
imposable
cette mesure destinée à relancer
l'audience du syndicalisme coûterait
environ une dizaine de millions de
francs enquête eve mettez une mesure qui
caresse dans le sens du poil les
centrales syndicales
la déduction des cotisations syndicales
sur la feuille d'impôts les syndicats
l'a réclamée depuis longtemps
espérant ainsi voir se redresser la
courbe de leur adhésion
résolument à la baisse le taux de
syndicalisation en france d'environ 15%
et le plus faible d'europe
alors comment financer les frais de
personnel les remboursements de prêts
immobiliers
l'organisation des congrès les syndicats
ont de plus en plus de mal à boucler
leur budget il apparaît normal que de la
même manière que tous les citoyens
peuvent déduire la participation des
heures d'intérêt collectif et d'intérêt
social évident il me paraît normal que
le syndicalisme
dans le cadre de ces organisations qui
ont droit à déduction fo la cftc et la
cgc la cgt dénonce les insuffisances de
la mesure j'observe qu'il est prévu de
ne dire qu'une partie des cotisations
syndicales donc c'est déjà une mesure
est en quelque sorte
ensuite si on compare le coup tu de
cette mesure l'allègement fiscal est
calculé pour représenter un milliard de
francs par contre les allègements
fiscaux prévus pour les sociétés
représentent 9 milliards c'est donc un
peu un cheval une alouette la cotisation
moyenne à un syndicat est d'environ 600
francs par personne et par an
quel pourcentage de cette somme sera
déductible pierre bérégovoy qui reçoit
lundi et mardi prochain les syndicats
dévoilera sans doute alors les détails
de son projet sensible amélioration
aujourd'hui à la bourse de paris où
l'indicateur de tendance a clôturé sur
une hausse de 0,44 % légère remontée du
dollar également qu'ils gagnent en moins
de deux centimes a été coté 6 francs 36
50 ce soir à new-york reprise de la
devise américaine cotait 6 francs 36 35
enfin baisse à wall street où le dow
jones a perdu 6 points 58 à 2030 et 1.65
la france à son tour touchée par
l'importation illégale de déchets
toxiques qu'alors que la grande bretagne
a refusé d'accueillir un cargo chargé de
deux mille tonnes de produits chimiques
un camion transportant six tonnes de
déchets hospitaliers a été intercepté
aujourd'hui près de st chamond
il a été renvoyé en italie aucune usine
de la région du rhône n'ayant
l'autorisation d'incinérer son
chargement
claude réjean des seringue usagée des
flacons de sang et même des pansements
juillet tous ces déchets devaient
prendre la direction de l'usiné de
traitement d'ordures ménagères de
saint-chamond dans la loire
ici on était évidemment scandalisé par
ce trafic de produits toxiques
d'autant plus que l'usld il n'est pas
équipé sur le plan sanitaire pour
recevoir ce type de déchets
d'après les documents qu'ils nous ont
fournis aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a
quelque part une manoeuvre un peu
troublé je pense que nous irons très
loin y compris jusqu'à un dépôt de
plainte pour savoir véritablement le
fond de cette affaire c'est grâce à un
contrôle douanier que le pot-aux-roses
si l'on peut dire a été découvert à
l'administration des douanes comme au
ministère de l'environnement on se veut
rassurant la législation française est
adapté l'ouverture des frontières
européennes n'empêchera pas les
contrôler ce système de transit me
permet de me d'apporter d'un pays
étranger jusqu'à jusqu'au fond des
terres du pays visité un chargement
douaniers toutefois la règle est très
strict
ce chargement ne peut qu'être en même
temps vous suivi ou précédé d'un
document voyez que s'appelle un ti de
transit et se dit de francs s'ils ne
libèrent le chargement qu'après 10 à des
services douaniers
les déchets ont été prestement renvoyé
en italie une enquête doit cerner les
responsabilités des trop nombreuses
sociétés en italie et en france qui sont
intervenus dans ce transport aussi
illégale que nauséabond un esthète et un
mécène à la tête de l'opéra de paris la
direction a été confiée aujourd'hui à
pierre bergé le pdg de la maison yves
saint laurent venu assez tard à la mode
pierre bergé est un passionné de musique
et de théâtre il est même dirigé
jusqu'en 1982 l'athénée où il avait
instauré il ya plus de dix ans les
lundis musicaux et aux vagues grégoire
pierre bergé passe de la haute couture à
la grande musique ascension que d'aucuns
prennent oil difficile pourquoi ce choix
et dg du groupe hills alors en créateur
et président de la chambre syndicale des
couturiers c'est donc un gestuel c'est
aussi un homme de culture c'est un
passionné de littérature de peinture et
d'art lyrique fondateur en 77 des lundis
musicaux de l'athénée sans oublier
également son engagement dans la
campagne du président mitterrand dont il
est un proche cet après midi en
compagnie de jacques lang visite d'un
opéra encore en travaux mais le chantier
c'est aussi le reste moi je ne trouve
pas que ce soit le haut
j'aime d'abord les difficultés alors là
je crois que je vais pas manquer et
ensuite vous savez c'était beaucoup
mieux d'avoir tout ce complexe réunis ça
permet d'arbitrer
ça permet de prendre des décisions ça
permet d'éviter des rivalités
ça permet de distribuer des masses de
budget ici ou là
problème aussi que tu es musicien le
directeur musical daniel barenboïm un
nouvel orchestre pour un nouvel opéra
les musiciens de garnier eux ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille
il faudra donc tranché j'aime bien les
artistes j'aime pas seulement les
musiciens les artistes en général et
j'aime bien les musiciens et comme une
gemme la concertation et que j'aime le
dialogue de préférence à l'autorité il
me semble qu'une récente entre eux et
moi tout est affaire sans doute mille
fallait d'un nouvel opéra plus
accessible à tous ce sera chose faite en
on nous l'a sur le reste est affaire de
petite main voyons maintenant les bons
chiffres du loto le 5 le 6 le 7 le 23 le
31 de 37 numéro complémentaire le 24 à
100 au pronostic de pirate bresse pour
le tiercé le quarté qui se courront
demain vincennes sur les dix-huit
partants pirette bresse vous recommande
de 15 le 5 le 14 le 11 le 18 le dise le
17 et le cect pluie nuages et orages la
météo se mettent à l'automne des
précisions de laurent cabrol et bien
vous allez accueillir en ce 1er
septembre la première perturbation du
mois elle est quand même bien bien
porteuse de pluie la preuve voici la
carte du temps prévu pour la mi journée
de demain avec vous le voyez des pluies
des ondées qui seront présentes sur la
bretagne la normandie les pays de loire
le nord la région parisienne le nord-est
et le centre à l'avant de cette zone
un temps qui sera maussade seulement en
fin de journée notamment sur le poitou
les charentes le morvan le jura la
lozère la lorraine l'alsace et la
bourgogne
attention aux orages sur les alpes et le
massif central de risque d'ondée
orageuses et puis sur le littoral
méditerranéen et les pyrénées ainsi elle
nue
je deux temps plus nuageux que nous
avancerons dans la soirée les
températures sont les températures qui
restent fraîches pour la saison
un peu à l'image de celle que nous avons
eue aujourd'hui de 18 à 30 degrés 24 à
26 degrés la moyenne nationale 26 degrés
à strasbourg et clermont ferrand et il
fera 28 degrés à nice et en corse 24
degrés ici dans la région de limoges et
à saint-yrieix nous élargissons notre
horizon un tour d'horizon donc hors de
nos frontières
barcelone 27 degrés du soleil vaincu
degrés à naples et comme un peu l'image
de ce qui se passe sur la france c'est
au nord de l'europe qui fera le moins
beau avec à prague
22 20 seulement 19 à copenhague et de la
pluie sur l'ombre voilà je vous laisse
voilà la fin de cette édition demain
6h45 vous retrouverez rejet abel pour
télématin avant le rendez vous du jazz
en type je vous souhaite une excellente
fin de soirée sur antenne
e